sur le canal latéral à la Loire ce grand
radeau avance tranquillement la
structure est une réplique d'un train de
bois attaché ainsi près de 100 stères
pouvaient être convoyées par voie d'eau
c'était simplement un moyen de transport
donc j'ai de l'empilage de bûche les
unes sur les autres qui sont enchassés
d'André dans ce qu'on appelle des
chantiers au départ et on avait une
forme sous forme de 36 mètres
quand on arrivait dans les environs
d'Auxerre on mettait deux trains là
derrière l'autre on allait faire 72
mètres à l'époque deux hommes
suffisaient à manœuvrer le train grâce
au courant l'association qui mène
l'expédition à plus de bras mais doit
s'inspirer de leur savoir-faire les
perches ne servaient pas à
faire avancer le train de bois les
perches servaient à éviter les obstacles
si on arrive à être bien coordonné oui
c'est pas très compliqué puis une fois
que ça a pris le rythme ça glisse je
dirais pas tout seul mais presque le
flottage a duré jusqu'à la fin du 19e
siècle chaque escale est donc l'occasion
de raconter cette histoire déjà
lointaine
François 1er il est tourné moi une
solution je veux du bois sur Paris une
manière d'entretenir la mémoire ça
reprend quand même toute une histoire en
fait de remonter le bois sur Paris donc
ça c'était quelque chose qu'on
connaissait pas du tout on savait pas et
donc c'était intéressant d'entendre
expliquer c'est intéressant voir des
gens qui le vivent comme ça c'est
dommage que on peut pas aller sur le
train bois qu'on peut pas avoir un peu
mieux mais c'est bien je trouve que
c'est très intéressant de connaître la
vie un peu de la région
la vie qu'ils ont vécu avant
en 2015 l'association flotte escale
avait acheminé un train de bois jusqu'à
Paris
cet été l'expédition navigra à travers
la Nièvre avec une arrivée à
Coulanges-sur-Yonne le 15 août
[Musique]